Jamie Carragher has said he will
apologize again after a video emerged
appearing to show the former Liverpool
defender spitting towards a football fan
and his daughter the video was filmed
after Manchester United's 2-1 victory
over Liverpool a Sky Sports spokesperson
has said it's unacceptable behavior and
we will be addressing it with Jamie in a
statement released just a few moments
ago at sky said Sky's takes this matter
extremely seriously and strongly
condemns Jamie's actions we have made
that clear to him in person today and
suspended him from his duties it falls
well below the standards we expect of
our people and Jamie joins me in the
studio now hello to Jamie just before we
talk let's have a look at the footage of
this incident Jamie Carr together Jamie
Jamie - 1 - 1 c1 mate
unlucky Jamie that shoe on that Jamie
kind of a spot on the door nice nice
very nice Jamie Carragher so Jamie I'm
recoiling watching that it is disgusting
how do you feel when you see it back
exactly the same you can't obviously
condone that's behavior no matter what
in any way shape or form the matter
where you are who you represent and
obviously of at Sky Sports our family
and the most important people really who
were probably mostly affected by a bit
of the family involved and especially
doing 14 year old doors why did you do
it a moment of madness really that it is
difficult for me to explain what
scripts baka fears like almost like her
and I was a body thing was just that
moment of madness for four or five
seconds and no matter what the
circumstances for anyone you can't ever
behave like that that is just no
acceptable and you describe it as a
moment of madness but you were a former
professional football if you're a
professional footballer for years you
should have been used to banter far
worse than this and you just ignore it
and carry on to be honest that is again
what you're actually thinking to be so
why did you react like that because
that's part of being a public figure or
sumana at times you know different
things get said but you don't yeah like
that's the only sign of youth like that
but the only time I ever react again
like that
Hey so again Hey I just have another
Shushan as I said it's just devastating
for the family involvement and also yeah
they from the old family but that's down
to my actions that's brought that on and
tell me about the family you called them
after the incident tell me about that
call yeah yes I was I call the family he
obviously would be upset and he
disappointed last night and it made the
fourteen-year-old girl yes and that is
the biggest sort of regret a lot of
regrets of what happened but simply the
biggest one is to for the 14 year old
girl to be sort of caught in the middle
of this of my altercation with the
father and that is something that
probably devastates me a little bit more
than than anything else really that a
young girl who wasn't involved in in
anything really
there's now become embroiled in this and
it doesn't matter who it was does it
there's no excuse for spitting at
anybody no of course yeah I'm not saying
that but what I mean is the fact that it
is a young girl feels maybe slightly
weird to me listen if it was your
daughter that song I'm in that position
I would exhaust exactly the same age as
that and if if someone had done that it
still fit we can find the way it's the
way I would react
what I would say for that person if ever
you know bumped into them something
because the way that father sees his
daughter the way I see my daughter but
that is me it is me because she gets of
course all of it is getting involved in
that type of situation but again all I
can do right now is sort of polish guys
as much as I possibly cases obviously I
can go back and I've done that with the
family
hopefully you know they accept that and
I'd like to obviously apologize again to
them oh and what happens now we've had
the statement from Sky's how you've had
discussions today so what happens for
you now what remains to be seen
I also would say is that is obviously
Sky's decision not my decision do you
think you deserve to keep your job we
again that's not my decision but they
will but from your point of view do you
think that after those actions you
deserve to be there on Monday Night
Football to be there as a face of the
broadcaster a face of football as a role
model do you deserve that position well
what I would say is I would there's no
doubt what I have done on softly after
the game is disgusting I apologized for
tea I'm getting vilified and rightly so
because if someone in that game had done
that that I was commenting on the
magician right at the little game I'd
have vilified them for the next few days
but what I was hope not just the sky but
for the the public who have known me for
possibly almost 25 years in the public
eye since I started playing it full of a
pool is that five seconds of madness
will not sort of take over everything of
what I've done now some people may like
me who may not like me even before this
this incident but hopefully going
forward I can show the real amaze I
don't feel that it's a real
representation of me and as I said
hopefully whether it be sky or the
general public will look at the 20 odd
years and I've made mistakes in those 25
years but this the mistake I've made
today is a huge one have you offered
your resignation or considered it I
haven't offered that no I'm just
speaking to
obviously people at Sky I'm away from
out what's the best way to to go forward
for me and sky but they've made it be
known they're obviously obviously bees
just read the statement that they're
very disappointed and understandably
shall I brought shame on the name of Sky
Force do you know the broadcast and the
game of football and so much is being
done to try and improve the image of
football and your actions have brought
the game into disrepute I agree yes it
has and you said we fought about role
models I think footballers people in the
job I do anyone public figure is a role
model whether you like it or not and
people do look up to us and look at our
actions so the way that we live in now
with social music a lot of young people
will have seen this clip as well so our
three Jamie and if one of my children my
five-year-old came home and spat I'd be
absolutely horrified and you're a grown
man
mmm I'd be horrified with my own
children and what I've done now is if I
add donor a five or six my old mother
nor father way they could help me it
would be the same as I said it was
difficult to explain the moment of
madness four or five seconds where I've
lost it basically and I've made a huge
mistake and I apologize for that I wish
I could go back and change it obviously
that's not the case all's I can do now
is obviously speak to you talk to the
family last night and hopefully moving
forward and speak to the family again
and and just apologize as much as I can
and behave in the right way and what
about your own kids what have they said
to you about it
well disappointed obviously a little bit
upset but you are highly paid you're in
a position of power that brings
responsibility with it what kind of
message do you think you have sent out
and how can you make amends for that I
pour a message not just about being in
the game or football it's a poor message
for every everyone out there man woman
or to your children let's say it's not
it it's the lowest of the low
I think whatever I was brought up as a
kid spittin Mazda and I've never done
before I'm sure you I'll never do it
again
but right now the only thing I can do as
I said there's common ear apologize and
trying get back to the person that in a
way what can you say to people watching
who you have let down not not least of
all the family involved in this but your
fans people who have looked up to you
people who've seen you as a role model
what do you say to them I apologize
because I know that will put a lot of in
my supporters families and I'm friends
in a very difficult position but the
most important people I'd like to
apologize to is the family involved
really they've actually now been dragged
into this media storm by yourself
because of my action which I'm sure will
not be nice to them especially the the
fourteen-year-old Yale so for me the
people who know me or look up to me as
you mention that's that for me to sort
out I'm just hopefully I think I can get
the chance again to maybe apologize or
meet or face-to-face with the family and
and sure I'm sorry every now and I just
want to bring in some tweets now of
course there's been a lot of reaction
since this footage emerged and Vinnie
Jones said spitting at 14 year olds
through a window he's presenting on TV
for Christ's sake he's supposed to be
one of the top men you can't condone
that whatsoever
it is filth it is absolute filth Joey
Barton who's been at the center a number
of controversies himself has said it's
absolute madness you just can't do that
in any fashion if Jamie is that annoyed
he should just keep his window up or
just tell him to mind his own business
it's disappointing because he's a good
pundit but you just can't condone that
and the former Liverpool player David
Thompson has said I've known Jamie
Carragher for 30 years and I can tell
you now that incident is completely out
of character for him Fair Play for
phoning the guy and his daughter up and
apologizing he's only human at the end
of the day and the frustration has got
the better of him the frustration
clearly did get the better of you Jamie
but there are no excuses as you yourself
her said and I ask you again do you
think that you deserve to keep your job
well
listen it doesn't matter I thought how
you say yes or no that is obviously down
to a the powers above again I would go
back to your head up high and still all
of it there as the face of the game
listen hopefully I can show people over
these next days or weeks the real me and
as I said before hopefully one morning
to Magnus will not cloud the judgments
of what people have of me whether that
was good or bad but of course this is a
bad stain on me my character my career
if you like and I mean the big thing
that I'm really disappointed this is
obviously the door so there was I'd
certainly didn't want that to happen or
get involved my frustration and what I
did which is an absolute disgrace is
with the the father and I really do I'm
still struggling to understand why you
were so frustrated because when you
listen to that clip Jamie it's just like
hearty banter isn't it - one mate mm-hmm
this is the difficult bit for me because
I don't want to sort of in some way give
a reason there's a lot of people to
think I'm given an excuse and it
happened two or three times but I've had
that plenty of times you never cherry
about and just whine the window up just
get out much I'm trying to say it's just
you get that that's part of being a
public figure and I've never reacted
like that before when I've had that so I
cannot explain the reason in those four
or five seconds why I reacted like that
it's never happened before it won't
happen again
this whole obviously sorry incident I've
dragged this family into is obviously
been devastating for them and
devastating for obviously trunks family
around myself and it's all come from me
and my actions and again there's no a
lot more hangouts with then actually
improved me behavior going forward and
trying to apologize again to the family
and people watching at home and before
we end it I also have to talk about the
driving and you are so busy arguing with
the other driver in the car who also is
using his mobile phone I have to say
while driving you're not looking at the
road he's filming you I mean the
consequences of this could have been far
worse than your reputation couldn't they
yes you're right yeah it could have been
and
that's something that no matter how bad
today is being for everyone the family
skysport and myself it could have been a
lot worse when you think what this was
on obviously it wasn't in the street it
was on busy traffic coming out to hit a
football ground so probably very lucky
people okay Jamie Carragher thank you
for talking to us this afternoon